oh man
i definitely overfilled it
okay
we've got a little ooze
i'm kelsey and i am team nacho cheese
dorito i'm iffy and i'm team cool ranch
now i think both are fine
but i definitely am partial to the nacho
cheese cool ranch is good because you
know a product is good especially in the
90s when it calls itself cool because
that was that's what it's like yo
i'm the coolest thing so today if he and
i are going to challenge tasty producer
alex traeger to make a giant burrito
with this is the base and luckily for us
this giant burrito will be split in half
one side is cool and the other half is
nacho cheesier well we'll soon find out
which is superior
[Music]
hey i'm alex and today i've been
challenged to make a giant dorito
burrito so we're going to see which half
of this giant dorito burrito comes out
on
topedo all right so i'm going to start
with the first half which is going to be
nacho cheese i'm gonna be making a
ground beef filling because ground beef
and nacho cheese goes really well
together we're gonna start with two
pounds of ground beef
nice sizzle i'm just gonna crumble this
down and cook it until the beef is brown
i'm just going to add in my white onion
now that my onions have cooked down a
little bit i'm going to be adding
some taco seasoning i'm just going to
eyeball this
if you're going to make this at home i
mean you can use your own spices cumin
garlic powder chili powder onion powder
any kind of powder all right so we've
got that seasoning in there it's
actually smelling pretty good i'm gonna
add in a can of diced tomatoes and green
chilies so i'm just going to give this a
few minutes just to like cook down any
of that extra liquid
i also don't want to add too much like
salt because i know the chips that we're
gonna put in the burrito have some
sodium in there so i don't want this to
be too salty all right so that is a wrap
on filling number one and we're going to
move on to filling number two so for the
cool ranch half i decided to use chicken
for the filling and that's because i
just feel like chicken pairs better with
ranch it's as simple as that so again
this filling is going to be pretty
simple we're just going to get this
chicken right in here and start to cook
that i really hope i can pull this half
off it just doesn't make as much sense
as a burrito filling but you know what i
don't make much sense most of the time
either i'm just gonna season my chicken
with salt and pepper and again i'm just
kind of eyeballing this but there's a
lot of chicken in here all right so my
chicken is cooked and i'm going to move
on to our chipotle ranch sauce because
the cool ranch flavor doesn't quite fit
within the ingredients of a burrito i
figured that using chipotle in the ranch
sauce we'll kind of tie those flavors
together i guess it's not exactly cool
ranch i feel like cool ranch is very
mild and these chipotle peppers are
pretty spicy but
whatever so i'm just gonna give this a
little bit of a blend
all right so for the chipotle ranch base
i'm gonna be adding some
mayonnaise
some sour cream
and some ranch
so i'm just gonna mix this up a little
bit and now i'm going to add in my
chipotle now again these are pretty
spicy the good thing though about the
ranch is that the fat from the
mayonnaise sour cream and the ranch will
cool down any of that spice in there so
it won't be too overpowering you get a
nice
like red color from the chipotles too
it's pretty good okay so now i'm going
to add my chipotle rain sauce to my
cooked chicken
all right so now our fillings are done
so let's start wrapping i lined this pan
with foil because i'm anticipating that
wrapping the burrito is going to be a
complete nightmare i'm hoping that
having the foil there will kind of help
me
seal it all together so i think the best
course of action is gonna be doing a
double layer of tortillas because i feel
like it's gonna be easier to wrap now
for my secret hack i'm gonna be
sprinkling some shredded cheese on my
tortilla and i'm gonna bake it so it
creates a bit of a glue so now i'm gonna
start assembling the rest of the burrito
i have some refried beans so the base of
my burrito is gonna be same on both
sides the fillings is what is going to
differentiate the flavors so this half
is gonna be the nacho cheese and this
half is gonna be the cool ranch i'm
deciding to add the layer of chips now
before my filling just so the chips are
kind of like encased in the middle and i
feel like it'll be easier to wrap when
the filling is on top rather than like
loose chips everywhere
and i'm gonna kind of like crunch them
down so they're a little flat
all right
this is very ridiculous so now i'm gonna
add my beef filling to our nacho side i
mean
this is kind of reminiscent of like
my order
at taco bell on the weekend it's like a
crunch off supreme i'm very worried
though that i've already overfilled and
now this half is for the chicken
cool i've got both sides of my toppings
on i'm gonna give it a little bit more
cheese and then we'll wrap this thing
i'm dreading that i definitely
overfilled it but you know i guess we
just gotta go for it
oh man
dang it maybe i just gotta go for it
[Music]
okay
we've got a little ooze i'm gonna try to
flip this side in now
okay that is a heavy burrito
[Music]
i'm just going to pop this in the oven
and just heat it all the way through so
we have a nice warm burrito
oh
baby
now that is a giant dorito burrito all
right let's bake this thing
all right so that went surprisingly well
i would say i know we
hit a little bit of a snag with the
filling but what's a burrito without a
lot of filling
a tortilla so now i'm going to jazz it
up put a little toppings on here and
we'll give it a taste
i'm shocked i pulled this off i have to
say it looks really good all right let's
get kelsey and iffy back in here to try
this monster of a burrito i hope i made
them proud
proud ito
[Music]
how are we gonna eat this is so large i
think it's just best if we cut off the
ends for you guys to try i'm so excited
to try this
oh my god so the sides are themed
[Music]
okay i'm ready that looks sick good luck
kelsey oh that was spectacular
cheers
um
whoa
there's just so much
but it's really good i took a huge bite
and forgot i had to talk after so
so this i would say is more of like a
classic burrito flavor with the nacho
cheese this is a little bit more of a
curveball with the cool ranch yeah this
felt really good just like i was just
eating a classic burrito okay oh this is
heavy
yeah mine is dense some girth to it
i taste that ranch
this might make me convert this is good
okay get my bag yeah there you go get in
there we're just like communal burritos
yeah
i'm gonna go with the ranch because i
like the chicken and the crunch you know
but i'm not hating on the classic cheesy
side right here you know it's hard to
choose you know it's a real selfie's
choice i think that i would actually
also go with the cool ridge because it's
like different and something new all
right this is too big for us to get on
room so let's show this with the office
yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
you